let's jump to colorado where historic
wildfires are getting even more
intense in that state hundreds of fire
crews are battling a blaze
in northern colorado that grew
dramatically yesterday producing heavy
smoke
and flames the town of grand lake had to
evacuate in fact at short notice last
night
and part of rocky mountain national park
is now closed
jonathan vigliotti is tracking the
wildfire that is burning an
estimated 6 000 acres every hour
it's getting worse a grand county
colorado resident records
in horror as the so-called east
troublesome fire
fills the sky with massive plumes of
dark smoke
it's bad it's really bad wind fueled
flames helped propel the fast-moving
wildfire wednesday afternoon
threatening hundreds of homes in the
towns of granby
and grand lake just two hours north of
denver
grant county sheriff's officers traveled
door to door
urging residents to leave their homes
following a mandatory evacuation order
in the late evening
officials say the east troublesome fire
which began last week
had already burned 30 thousand acres by
the time it exploded last
night it's one of several major fires
currently burning
across the state including the cameron
peak fire
which has burned over 200 thousand acres
the most
in state history we are in extreme
drought conditions right now
and what we need is enough snow and
enough moisture to really
change those small fine fuels an
estimated 442 thousand acres of land in
colorado
and wyoming are being affected by the
wildfires
fire crews say that they will look for
significant snow
in the coming weeks to aid in their
fight
for cbs this morning jonathan vigliotti
los
angeles it's just terrifying